німецький бундесвер у латвійського ніж
йти або фейкові компанії приводом
стала чуйна prime впевнено з gold у
вані та солдатам і напав на літні
дівчата
e-mail про нього вірна закрут
депутати литовського своєму поліції
вечері 14 лютого
цим вже на доступний день куліть азії
сунув а вони дівчини вони сувої у на
весну і в міноборони не машини vpn і не
цифри кого атака на бунда свої рота на ту
gangster's абсолютно очевидно шиються
було з відома акція було з компанії від
шоу крім ви paddock покажи джаз про тих
хто цезар був
а також про їхнє ти ви я нічого на
можеш сказати алло.
від сили з прямого на дезінформація c
факт на місяць за міністерством оборони
литви поважають потім вже стоять біля
росіян і випадуть на дам скандал на
школу виведення нових голосування
російському але я дівчина елізи
у берліні рік тому to die російський
перший канал російську історію про будь
intous ґрунтування 13 річкова дівчина
мігрантами в контексті міграційну
щури в Європі фриче до солдата
бундесверу припав на розширення
злочинності війська натомість 5 гривні в мені
мічені в литві за крима разом руку ще
за 120 кілометрів вид російського
ексклаву калінінграду мангая бомбив
співаком кум там ми тут готова дав
занурення за в домбаї води націю нині ми
на стадії раз буду ви і всю групу з осіб
прямо так часті але литовської бригади
частини назальних потужному стайні щось таким
чином ми рибного гама і в шкарпетку гострим
овальний потенціал альян ренату
за галон тут до літа миють розмістить і
блузку тисячі суду темрява атаку штанг
це енчу ризикову техніку німці
бельгійці нідерланд дивно ми з
розум і злі топ тим і просто стоять і
реальніше завантаж над чи анексії росією
у криму то винної на сході україни
жителі литви вич його it'sa грози відразу
того махають гарантії bespeco
адже заходу